hello hello may I speak to Michael Ross
bash please you're speaking to thank you
very much my name is Adam Smith calling
from nobelprize.org with the website of
the Nobel Prize um so I suppose it's
funny in a way that a prize for working
on the molecular mechanisms of the
circadian rhythms is announced in a way
that disrupts your own sleep cycle
indeed ironic yes I hadn't thought about
that
I must confess but absolutely yes how
did you hear the news on the night table
by my bed woke me out of a deep sleep
and the gentleman
Thomas Pearlman yes he told me the news
and I was shocked breathless really
literally my wife had start breathing in
a way this is something that everyone
takes for granted there adaptation to
night and day but it's sort of the
original adaptation to environmental
influence isn't it yes it is before the
atmosphere had its current this
constitution before
nutrition was anything like it is today
the earth rotate on its axis light-dark
cycle impinge on the beginning survive
and I suppose it's hard for people to
imagine how different it was thirty
years ago when you were starting this
work that you know you were real
pioneers in linking genes to behavior
right it's true it's true we didn't
think of ourselves as that you know
everybody that there since there's an
element of craft to the work you know
we're putting one foot in front of the
other trying to try to you know get get
more experiments to work than fail but
but in hindsight yes there's some truth
to that and the prize is also a
celebration I suppose of your close
working relationship with Geoffrey
holders it is it is yes long long long
partnership what made you such a strong
team we were we were very we had very
two things we were very good friends
personally before in fact we started to
work together and secondly we had
complementary skill sets together he's a
bit of a maverick riding Harley
Davidsons and the like that's the sort
of thing yes and the like yes that's
that's that's that's a good way to put
it very British and very and very
appropriate will we look forward to
welcome you to Stockholm in December of
course you will
great ok well enjoy your day and thank
you thank you very much thank you bye
bye